trouves tu que celle ci ressemble un
train
pourtant c'en est un et s'appelle gérard
antoine et son grand-père voyage au
centre durant boli train se livraient je
pensais par les équipes du musée
entraîne les visiteurs au temps de jules
verne
c'est facile mais des foyers d'être un
compte rond point qui sont un peu caché
son papa y est venu il y a à peu près où
30 35 ans ça et donc ça lui avait bien
plus à lui avait donné lui même le goût
de faire des maquettes puis je pensais
que ça pouvait faire plaisir aux petits
fils qui aime bien les trains chercher
parmi les milliers de trains ou même les
imaginer deux livrets sont disponibles
en fonction des âges ce vendredi 21
février les petits visiteurs sont
appelés à imaginer leur propre
locomotive
si j'étais un train est un atelier d'une
quinzaine de minutes
c'est grâce au nom de ses trains et à la
description qu'on leur donne c'est de
dessiner un train pour les plus grands
d'imaginer à quoi il pouvait ressembler
et pour les plus petits pour en coller
des gommettes donc ça c'est plutôt pour
les maternelles ils sont aidés un bien
sûr c'est un moment de partage avec les
parents ou les grandes soeurs et frères
et si le temps le permet
samedi 22 février solène prolongera le
voyage avec mini la locomotive à essence
tourne autour du musée alors adultes
comme enfants en voiture